في المقابله اعلنت احزاب عده مقاطعه
للانتخابات التشريعيه ضمن المسار الجديد
الذي اعلنه الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد وتضم
قائمه المقاطعين لهذه الانتخابات كيانات
سياسيه مختلفه مثل جامعه الخلاص الوطنيه
المكونه من عدد من الاحزاب السياسيه
والهيئات المدنيه من بينها احزاب حركه
النهضه وقلب تونس وائتلاف الكرامه وحرك
تونس الاراده وحزب حركه امل المعارضه الى
جانب تنسيقيه الاحزاب الديمقراطيه
الاجتماعيه التي تتشكل من خمسه احزاب
يسريه وديمقراطيه واجتماعيه هي التيار
الديمقراطي والحزب الجمهوري والتكتل
الديمقراطي وحزب العمال وحزب القطب كما
اعلن الحزب الدستوريه الحر وحزبه افاق
تونس مقاطعهما لهذه الانتخابات في المقابل
يسانده كل من حزب حركه الشعب وحسبه تيار
الشعبيه مسار الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
تموز منذ الاعلان عن الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه للرئيس سعيد